this is a production of Cornell
University plus I'll turn it over to you
and yeah we'll take it from here
an insect it could be a disease okay so
any any type of a pest that it crops up
in us in a farming system can be seen as
a problem in itself and that gives you a
very that gives you a very different
solution then the problem becomes how do
you kill the past or it can be seen as a
symptom of the direction that your
system has gone in I have found more and
more and some sometimes it's not real
apparent but by introducing the right
new species to the system we can change
the system so that it doesn't become the
ideal host for what we consider the
problem and I'm going to digress a
little bit because I we've got a perfect
example that was done here at Cornell of
this concept but it's with a little
different crops and that's dry beans
where and that one of the early soil
health tests came out of this where we
were growing dry beans and then waiting
five years and coming back and the same
disease complex that had been in the
roots of the dry beans was back almost
as if we hadn't rotated and we were
blaming the varieties we were looking
for organic fungicides until Georgia
Bowie took me aside once and said this
problem has nothing to do with your
reactive stuff it has to do with how
you've been farming with what your
system is what he explained was that we
were wrote
two grasses and other legumes the other
legumes were co-hosts to the same set of
problems that were in the dry bean roots
and specifically there were two problems
that were building up because of our
lack of diversity one was the fungi the
Pythium or Isaac tonyia the Fusarium the
other was pathogenic nematodes which
were opening up the roots and creating a
big highway for all the pathogens to
move in and whenever we had a wet spring
in that situation we had the roots rot
off and a lousy crop of beans what
George suggested was why don't you mix
up your system a little bring in some
other species wheat and this this is
actually the perfect slide for it after
the corn we decided to shift gears we
frost seeded yellow mustard yellow
mustard gives off has glucosinolates in
it it gives off a cyanide gas at vial
fumigate the soil kills the pathogenic
nematodes but it also seems to get rid
of the fungal complex and within a
couple of years of changing our system
our dry bean yields had gone from about
900 pounds to where we actually had one
field that produced 4000 pounds of dark
red kidneys it on average it doubled our
yields just to add and this would have
been early spring we've frost seeded
no-tell after corn in March yellow
mustard and incorporated it in June when
it was time to plant the dry beans the
big concept here I don't want to belabor
that particular practice and we have to
separate between systems and practices
you know we've got a problem and you
described it really well Matt was we
tend to have this mindset if I want to
add this really good practice to a
system but if it's not compatible with
the system it's not going to work so in
in this case we changed our system to
remove the reason that we had the
buildup of the problem now when we try
to create a system that incorporates the
rolled rye in the no-till and again this
is a good example of how do we reimagine
the system
but I think we're gaining quite a lot by
having more diversity in our farm by
eliminating some of these pitfalls that
create pest problems and I there's a
piece of research that I would love to
see done here at Cornell Penn State or
anywhere that they're willing to do it
is I believe every species that we grow
changes the soil and makes it the ideal
environment for some other species it
makes it a terrible environment for some
make it's probably neutral for others
and we have this spectrum just like with
herbicides there's a control spectrum I
would like to see some work done on how
these species interact so when we put
Ryan to roll it my observation is that
why is either neutral or beneficial to
soybeans it's extremely hazardous to
some other species in fact once I
thought I had a great idea this was back
when I first started talking with Matt
of picking other allelopathy species so
that we could follow the Rye with
no-till sunflowers that was a bad idea
rye will literally kill sunflowers it's
one of the most easily controlled
species for the effects that the Rye has
and we call that allelopathy I think
we're I think we're oversimplifying it
allelopathy is plant chemicals that are
given off by the roots but there are
other modes of action that are going on
a plant like rye that uses a lot of
nitrogen is also suppressing species
that need a lot of available nitrogen
every species has a group of microbes in
the soil if we don't have the right
microbes in the soil then we're
suppressing something and that's where
we got in trouble growing other legumes
with dry beans we were building up us a
lot of species in the soil that made
that soil not be a healthy environment
for the crop we were trying to grow so
this inner species type of research I
think could inform us in our no-till
systems as to how do we use the cover
crops as a way to improve the
environment for the intended crop and
then how do we create it into a circle
so that we're actually optimizing the
system using the right cover crops to
give the desired conditions a few things
that we've tried on the farm and I'm way
out ahead of the science here but we
have to try new things to take
observations is we've noticed that if we
put tillage radish in the fall with our
winter grains that we actually have a
slight increase in yield one to two
pounds of tillage radish put in with
winter wheat has given us and observed
yield boost we also have noticed that
when we've had problems with the rolled
R I sometimes even though it improves
soil structure if we've had really bad
weather and especially bad weather when
we establish the Rye we've got some
legacy effect of not really great soil
structure it makes the planter network
as good makes it harder to get the seed
placement where you want so by putting
the tillage radish in the system our
theory is that we're going to be
penetrating the soil loosening it up and
actually mitigating possible legacy
problems in the soil structure improving
the soil health and if it is at a if
it's in at a population that helps or as
neutral to the Rye we could pre we could
be creating a better root situation for
no telling in to I've seen suggestions
that maybe we should be putting them in
rows that would be a really interesting
concept but again I'm out ahead of where
the science is I'm trying to throw out
ideas format I'll Drive him crazy with
ideas before
and I'm Klaus Martin's we're certified
organic farmers for over 20 years we
farm just an hour from here we've worked
very closely with Cornell ever since I
can remember and a lot of the work
that's been done here we've cooperated
with and advised and and I think it's
been a very complimentary thing where
observations made in the field are being
tested here we're finding that the
research that is being done I'm gonna
put in a plug for the farming systems
trial the long term organic farming
systems trial here was informed by
what's happening out on farmer's fields
but at this point it is been consistent
enough and has moved ahead far enough so
I think it's going to start informing
what farmers do know that that's been a
real big benefit and I think there's
been a synergy between Cornell and the
organic farmers in this region that has
resulted in Cornell being ahead of most
of the rest of the country on organic
research but also the New York farmers
being ahead of farmers and other parts
of the country and I have I talk at a
lot of Midwestern meetings where people
come up and they're envious of us for
living next to Cornell for the kind of
support we've gotten in the quality of
the research that has helped us move
ahead in our yields so I'm going to drop
that part of the talk and go back to
adaptive management I think that's what
you started talking about and it really
is important so we'll go back to 2016 we
had planted 70 acres which was a big
jump for us of Rye for role down and
believe it or not we were much drier
than musgrave we had less we had three
inches less rain during the summer than
musgraves did and that was kind of a
disaster in terms of drought we had
three inches of rain total from May 26
until the end of the growing season and
had gone six weeks with under an inch so
you can imagine what our no-till
soybeans look like they actually yield
it only 200 pounds less
ones at Musgrave but we could have done
really really well because I did
chickened out on our worst field when I
saw how dry it was and we decided to
harvest at his Ryland the Rye llege was
a really profitable crop because in the
severe drought forage prices doubled so
it was an adaptive management where even
though we had to change our plan we were
able to change it to something more
profitable now hindsight's 2020 I should
have done that with all of our in fact
one of our fields some amount if
somebody had grown hairy vetch once and
it was a mixture of hairy vetch and rye
that was about nine tons or nine
thousand pounds per acre of dry matter
the stuff was over the hood of a big
tractor by about two feet I imagine the
forage that we could have harvested on
that instead of getting a piddly 900
pound crop of soybeans but what we
followed that with and because this was
our worst field we knew that there
wasn't enough water you couldn't even
plow that land it was so dry so we know
tilled sorghum Sudan grass into it
sorghum Sudan grass it was that was a BM
our sorghum Sudan is able to tolerate
much drier soil than soybeans we
actually harvested our biggest and most
profitable crop off the poorest field
because we have pulled a big crop of
chop triage and then we pulled two
cuttings of sorghum Sudan it's amazing
you can get as much dry matter as you do
from a crop like that but this kind of
adaptive management really drives
researchers crazy because it can't be
replicated it's it's kind of a
seat-of-the-pants thing but it is its
opportunities that we can build into a
system like that and by going from the
what would have been the crimp try to
harvesting forage putting in sorghum
Sudan we went back to a winter grain
which made a good crop the next year so
that that's one of those adaptive
management tools
another adaptive management tool and
we've been talking with Aaron Silva in
Wisconsin is the system was developed at
about route 80
and Raya is crimped at the right time of
year to get the best soybean yield if
you're at that latitude we're really
close to route 90 a little different
latitude there's about a 10 day
discrepancy between when you ought to be
planting soybeans and when you ought to
be rolling the Rye determinated what
they're doing in Wisconsin is just
planting the Rye when it's time or
planting the soybeans when it's time to
plant soybeans and then crimping the Rye
later when it's time to crimp the ride
when we were coming into the severe
drought in 2016 we actually had plenty
of dry matter and we crimped well before
an thesis to stop water loss the reason
we had even the nine hundred pounds were
that really miserable drought was that
we were able to stop much of the water
loss when we came back at about two
weeks the soybeans were this high and
the Rye was getting right back up so we
took the crimper and I tried several
different things but we went in the
opposite direction and we had did no
damage whatsoever to those soybeans
running over them and they were drilled
they were narrow rows but we didn't hurt
them with the tires and we didn't hurt
them with the crimper and we were able
to flatten and terminate those that rye
going in the opposite direction a couple
weeks later when it was time when it was
an thesis and it was time to terminate
[Music]
kill of the ride Chesley Clause the
saying that's what we're getting and
maximizing our soybean yield and so this
idea of this threshold you know
maximizing your bottom s I think like
you say that that may work better south
of here that's right and just deal with
whatever we need to with the right not
being ready he's coming back and again
we're doing something else
yeah pretty consistent never see the
entire yield so a couple of months ago
we brought in somebody to do a program
at our farm and we talked about New York
is too far north you know all these
advantages you have at route 80 but this
guy was growing organic no-till grains
and vegetables in Germany I know it
would be like being up north of Toronto
far north of Toronto for at the latitude
he was working at and he showed us some
tools some techniques and some ideas
that were giving him extremely
successful results far north of where it
should be possible to do right I I met
one of his classmates once he'd been
he'd went to school in Germany and the
professor was talking about no-till and
saying organic no-till is very
successful talking about the Rodale
system but it can't possibly be done
this far north and this is one of these
guys that you can picture him he popped
out and so I've been doing it for three
years what's the problem I'm sure you
love students that do that kind of thing
so what Yan Hendrick has done he had
looked at what is it that tillage does
and how do we achieve that without
tillage and I think those are really
important questions to frame so that
that kind of opens it up to more ideas
what he was his goal was actually to
grow vegetables and he came up with the
idea of transfer mulch he made some
mental filters in his mind these were
rules that he farmed within so he said
one rule
I'm not going to import any organic
matter from off the field so within
those rules he would take cover crop
like when you head to clover
if he didn't need it for mulch didn't
need it for anything else he would chop
it and cover it to ferment and would
store it or if he had beds he would chop
the cover crop from between the beds and
put it on the beds
he found that when you crimped and you
didn't have enough biomass to control
the weeds you could bring in transfer
mulch to get up to the right amount of
biomass and control the weeds the other
thing he found with the transfer of
mulch and this is the other thing
tillage does is it produces it releases
fertility now when you till you start a
biological fire in the soil you're
burning up organic material and
releasing minerals that the crop that's
growing hopefully needs at the right
time is when they're released because if
you're if you do tillage that releases
these minerals not when the crop needs
them it's basically recreational tillage
and you're putting stuff out there that
either is going to leach into the water
or the weeds are going to use it and
that that's one of the problems of
tillage it can actually increase weeds
even though it's a tool used to reduce
weeds so he started looking at how much
mulch does it take to control the weeds
but also what composition of mulch do
you need
what CN ratio and what chap length so
what particle size to release fertility
in time with when the crop needs it now
those concepts really stretched my
thinking and he along with these
concepts he said well let's look at this
crimper and when you use this the
organic matter lasts the longest and we
had a little discussion about the
temperature so he said how about if I
sharpened the backside of those blades
and put a hitch on the other end so now
if he wanted the organic matter to last
as long as possible he would run it the
way we're doing here if he was in a
hurry if he wanted to warm the ground up
quicker and wanted it to break down
faster remember it's a it's a cool
damp environment where he is he would
run in the other direction and it would
chop and he could speed up the
degradation in the breakdown by about 40
percent then he got a machine that would
actually it was a flail more it's a
little higher tech than the ones we have
here that would cut right to the surface
and shred the material and that would
increase the breakdown speed by more
than double so that gave him some tools
that he could use to make those
disadvantages that he had in to
advantages there's no reason we can't be
using those tools I would love to see
some work done here with you know what
happens if we use use this for chopping
you know maybe if we're crimping the
second time over we ought to be cutting
that could be cutting the heads off late
enough so that we're not getting the
grain ripening afterwards so sorry I'm
not giving you a whole lot of answers
here I'm just trying to throw out
questions for the researchers
but I
things like one of the major bottlenecks
is rolling
getting that time period right
I'm involved in this program but also
people are looking at it serial and I'm
trying to look at earlier Rosalie and
their species so that's why we're
looking at partly because it matures a
little bit earlier we thought that we
get in and deal with the battery we just
were getting as much weed suppression
with that so people are thinking about
it and approaching in from different
ways breeding is one of them but and
Hendrik was also using mixtures and he
he was doing prescriptions depending on
what you were going to plant afterwards
and when it was going to be planted for
things that would be later or earlier so
it was not just the mechanical but this
this is work that's really compatible
with what you're doing
I see one of the barriers to growers
implementing some of these
and the last seniors and we're more
expensive than the road
blowers you just don't run it with the
younger in the video
I've actually tried called the mulcher I
I've never done the the mower but this
was this was actually one of behind
Andrews point he said he didn't have a
lot of money and he said a lot of
farmers don't he said just try things
you know and it's the called Amal true
did a great job for me but this this
crimper isn't that expensive at least on
in the no-tell planners and drills can
be rented oh okay that's a good
challenge for your Conservation District
in our County the Conservation District
had one for twenty years now there are
five of them in the area that are for
rent that farmers have we actually have
a neighbor who is a brilliant no tiller
he's conventional he bought an old
single disc drill and he waits until a
rain and he gets his cover crops to
start as nice as the people who spent
$50,000 on a drill that's about a
fifteen hundred dollar machine just but
he waited for conditions to be right so
when the soil was soft enough that
single disc opened it up and he got a
stand
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu